will you do me the honor of being my  wife every room nothing would please me  more than to be your wife  so that's a yes yes wait a second I'm  just like giddy and I'm like because  when I get nervous I laugh and I don't  know why but I do it's just so not fair  Treena boyfriend in the midst of my  dinner had to propose to her what kind  of sense does that make  [Music]  [Music]  you may kiss your man  you may kiss them in the mouth face it's  got to be right here so there's David  and tomorrow Trina I won't talk to that  [ __ ] [ __ ] say you can't leave now it's  not a good look for you it's not a good  look for you  boy my man you stepped up today it's not  a good look  okay congratulations may I have many  more days aged there it is Tamar please  come back and sit down I cannot believe  that she got up like that  she shouldn't just express herself and  you know kept a moving  [Music]